hi and welcome to episode number 15 of
the weekly Google cloud platform pod
cast iron franciscan boy and i'm here
with may very very distinguished
colleague mark Mandel hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good friends ask how you
doing today very happy very happy about
actually very nice weekend that we spent
a lot hackathon yes vision and also very
excited about the Compton we're gonna be
talking with burnt our wall sorry I did
it for this time it annoys you it's very
top are sorry product manager for grp
see ya very exciting an interview and
GOP see is very interesting stuff yeah
i've been using it for a little bit with
all the projects like demos on corporate
entities and stuff like that me too very
very cool yeah and after that we're
gonna also be talking with sarah
robinson again yeah we've got a really
interesting question of the week talking
about firebase and mobile application
development and since we don't know any
anything about it we've decided that
sorry i should be back you know at the
end of the pn of Bacchus will have sarah
back to talk about firebase and mobile
phones wonderful but before we get into
those things I think we have a
particularly special cool thing of the
week yeah it's a thing of the way they
so cool that I almost considered editing
the podcast from last week to be able to
talk about it yeah but we decided not to
but it's very exciting it's about
Spotify of course oh yeah oh oh what's
what if I've never heard of it polyfit
yes this little thing is they play music
or some yes something yeah yeah there's
Swedish pinned island now they're really
cool I've actually been using Spotify
for a very long time yeah even before
they even considered start working with
Google and so I'm very excited that
they're finally part of our customers
yeah so they actually wrote a blog post
yeah about how they move they're
basically their entire infrastructure
over to Google cloud platform yeah so
they could work what is it 75 million
users like it is primis and that's
pretty cool yeah and it's not only the
fact that they moved to Google cloud
platform it's pretty cool but for me the
coolest bar is that not only it's like
they did
a little bit of a shift on left like
whatever infrastructure they were
already using they moved it to the club
but also they started using a bunch of
other Google cloud platform managed
services yeah which is pretty awesome
and I have the list here yeah the ones
are quite like like on the big data site
especially we've talked to you know
about with Felipe about bigquery and
stuff like that but they were using like
Hadoop MapReduce hive bunch of homegrown
stuff yeah and they basically came
across and started using all our stuff
so Google pub/sub cloud dataflow
bigquery Cloud Data proc so they found
like well I I can only assume better
solutions within what we had for them
and we'll manage from trying to manage
their own stuff on their own end yeah
and apparently they were so happy that
some engineers started tweeting about it
and there's have this tweet from I'm
gonna go him por la mia uh because I
think he's French and if he's not French
hey bald is an invitation for you to
come to the podcast yeah yeah tell us
literally how your name is pronounced
hear ya and you can also tell us about
your history how big how they go using
google cloud platform and so on but
there's actually one specific tweet
where he tweeted Google's big queries
that bomb I can start with to the two
billion things and compute summarized
down to 20k in less than one minute
which is pretty impressive it is indeed
pretty impressive so yeah we're good
love to have him so if by any chance you
are listening to it or if any of our
listeners knows personally polymer how
many degrees of separation can we get
yeah I'm sure that someone that we know
my know was someone that knows him so
just let me let's make this happen
excellent yeah so yeah on top of that
they're also using they're basically
using the whole club cloud platform they
also using cloud datastore and cloud big
table and they're also using cloud VPN
and Club router and so on yeah so yeah
it's a bunch of things I think it's a
very cool it's very cool thing that we
finally have someone as big a Spotify
and so public cuz now i can go and tell
to my mom definitely not technical it
means no spot eastern so your mom
doesn't know snapchat is pretty much
what you're saying
she's I don't know snapchat is probably
better for yes but if I probably a
better one yeah wonderful well that
sounds really cool um so why don't we
have a chat with Varun I really want to
hear about your pc right let's go with
that let's do it we are joined today by
a very special man man by the name of
Varun tell wha Varun is the product
manager for a lovely little project
called grp see Varun how are you doing
today good thank you so much more thank
you very much for having us we really
like having you here yeah so we're gonna
be talking about grp see which is a
great project ivory love it cuz open
source and everything is get out there
and everybody can use it everybody's
using it actually lots of people using
it but before that I can use it a little
bit about yourself yeah sure Thank You
francisc so my name is Varun as Mark
said I'm a product manager on project
project called grp see Google remote
procedure calls some people like to fill
it wait wait wait i heard that that was
not according to the faq grp c stands
for grp see Ramon crossley recall which
is amazing exciting ok ok resume is a
recursive cursive like yeah we could we
like the question yeah exactly ok sorry
for interrupting so I have actually
recently taken on this role and but you
know it is born out of something called
stubby which google has been using for
many many years and it's awesome that we
have now open sourced it and the
community is can use all the great
things at Google as well so I'm super
excited about the opportunity is about
taking j or pc to enterprise companies
to the community and to all the new use
cases of microservices cloud and IOT
cool so okay so we've we've seen that gr
pc has use cases like one of the use
cases microservices so makes it perfect
for nowadays like everybody's using
micro services but how could you
describe grp see in like two sentences
what is it exactly you can use three
it's okay oh yeah are you having like
your relevant yeah you're allowed
well yes if I had to say it in like one
line it would be gr pcs a is a high
performance and efficient now open
source RPC framework that puts mobile
and HTTP to first so it's really a
general-purpose RPC framework that
anybody can use to connect two systems
go and you know it supports a whole ton
of languages cool so let's maybe go a
little higher up like we say RPC what is
our PC stand for what is like what is
that and where do people use that right
so as as many of you in this audience I
suppose with no RPC stands for remote
procedure call I'll take you back to CS
101 and our undergrad schools which is
you know basically the way we were
taught all of us were taught our pcs is
you know you have a process but it's not
running on the same machine so it's a
remote process so how do you call it you
basically RPC use a technology where you
define what that service is you take all
the arguments from the calling machine
you serialize you do marshaling send
them over the wire as an unmarked
happens takes the arguments does the
processing and cents back right so
that's how conventionally we've all been
taught RPC in that that's what at the
core of it it is you know request
response but these days RPC frameworks
have become pretty sophisticated they
can do synchronous asynchronous
streaming and all those good things nice
so by the description you gave if I gave
that description to anyone I'm sure than
ninety-nine percent of people could say
Oh rest what is the difference with it
right so so restez has pretty much
become a standard in how people expose
their sort of services you know used to
be the the soaps and wisdoms and sort of
rest really took on with with the growth
of Internet and sort of browsers and
mobile phones interacting with Internet
services primarily because you know it
all it was is sort of HTTP methods
and if they could flow through proxies
and firewalls and easy to call is it to
test the rest is it is great this is you
know by no means gr pc is is saying that
vest is not good rest continuous to
dominate and it's great for a lot of use
cases as a lot of you know arrest is a
very resource oriented so it's time for
representational state transfer you know
you basically define the resources on
the server side and you know HTTP GET
get put post methods on top of each of
those resources basically cloud
operations on all your server side
resources is how rest works which is
great what we have seen is when you know
when when people really really care
about performance and they care about
what is being what format is being
carried on the wire what you know and
trying to squeeze out the best
performance that is where things like
grp see shine where we serialize into
binary over the wire as opposed to
carrying json when we've seen in some
cases you know even crazy improvements
like 100x if there is by just by
changing that the other thing is for for
a data center and cross data center
large-scale operations like you know the
internet companies of the world 11
performance is critical second there are
a lot of use cases where it's not just
you know request response these days
it's like with push notifications and
streaming data sources and you know
streaming data from all kinds of
connected devices people really want
bi-directional streaming both climb to
server and serve it with line and you
know this is where again grp see is
great and because it allows you to
establish you know one tcp connection
and send a ton of messages on both sides
right with having efficiency on the wire
so I think these are some of the use
cases where we are seeing adoption of of
grp see the other big difference i would
say is
in terms of the mental model is if i
were to put it in like very very you
know simple terms rest is very much
nouns oriented and injeel pcs kind of
herbs oriented right so the way you
define your services is what your
systems and services can do and this is
the service definition language which is
it which is google's implementation is
based on proto this you know protobuf is
what google uses internally but grp see
as a protocol is designed so that you
can use any idea any interface
definition language and short idea and
basically define your services using any
IDL and we are just the transport which
will carry our messages efficiently
right so you mentioned IDL what that's
ideal stand for yeah so ideal is is
interface definition language the
implementation at Google for grp see
uses protobuf which is a way you define
your services so in you know to take it
a step further you define your methods
in proto we give you a compiler using
which you you know which is called pro
to see you compile using that you get
your client and server side stubs and
then you communicate at a high level
yeah that's what it is that that sounds
a little bit likes water right like yes
that you're describing methods and
resources yeah so yes so I got so I got
is great it's it's um so yes and no
would be the short answer right there so
swagger is so I got is great in terms of
its tooling around you know doc gen
testing sharing us server specific
services specification and so on and
it's greatly adopted for rash services
but we we don't think of we think of
swagger as a great complementary
technology that we want to actually
leaned in and adopt by having ways to
you know convert some of these observe I
dll files pro
into swagger and then allowing people to
use all kinds of downstream swagger tool
chains you know tools that they are
familiar with so they don't have to
really change the way they are using
things in terms of dog generation
testing you know things like API
Explorer and so on so good that mean
that at some point we might have some
protocol buffer definitions and some
tool to say generate the service
specification that corresponds to that
and then use my swagger Explorer to do
exactly like to go over my protocol
offer definitions you you read my mind
that's awesome okay is that actually
coming can you can you say a little bit
i like is it something that people are
working on all right it's it's it's
actually being worked on I can go a step
further and say it's about like it's
being used internally nice nice so it's
it's not like you know just an idea it's
actually bad kind of works like I know
so so coming soon is what I can easily
say yeah that's that's very good I'm
very excitable that that's awesome okay
so just to just to kind of put a put a
bow around a little bit so development
flow EG RPC so we've got this this idea
of the den official language so i write
my protobuf file what does that kind of
look like what is that and I was kind of
hard to save my voice but what like sort
of general concepts how do we how does
that sort of look yep so so a proto and
you know if you go to grp 0 do we have
we have great hello world example stew
to actually get you started on that but
essentially you you'd if you say service
any method name let's say it's hello
world you say service hello world you
say it's a cenar pc input you know let's
say let's say i want to say hello mark
so string name and you know output
string as well so that's all you're
defining then you say your message which
is the actual payload that will be used
for the communication so you basically
define service and message you can think
of it in sort of conventional sort of
terms as your methods and you're sort of
data schema and you define those and we
give you a compiler to basically compile
and get you know code generated in 10
languages nice so you know this I head
into the wrong it's actually 10 language
we're not gonna ask you to see all of it
pretty much any language I'm actually
wondering if I can remember drop my head
I see if I get this right I don't know C
C++ PHP Java Ruby ah how you go okay I
really Francis with you hyphen Objective
C Objective C node no yeah that's yeah
there we go so yeah okay so basically
but at the end what we're doing is what
you write in protocol buffer definition
is basically like an interface a Java
interface or a going to face really like
it just your interface with the method
names and the inputs on the output and
then you're gonna alter generate the
code for the client and the server and
then the server is gonna be like oh you
have to actually define whatever hello
world actually does right right cool
that's some good that sounds good
alright cool and so once you've
generated that code it gives you a
server that you can run in that language
and you start it and you had a client
and you can interact with as well yeah
so you call him from clients tubs and
then you test and deployed excellent so
we touched a little bit on before you
said it like you said 100 times sort of
thing I know performances depends but
like latency performance if you seem
like like any sort of benchmarks or
something that you've seen that sort of
gives people a bit of at least at least
somewhat of a sense of like how fast
this thing could really go yeah so you
know performance is a tough one to
answer in because it depends depends is
the right answer for kids it's a
universally right answer for performance
questions but we we have seen you know
in all the i would say three kinds of
use cases one is you know service to
services in microservices world we have
seen an example from core OS who was you
know using g RPC extensively in the
distributed key value store called hcd
which is also actually one of the under
pending
cobra ladies and they actually put out a
blog post think it was the end of last
year December 15 where they compared
with JSON RPC and you know this is you
know simple put requests for FCD which
for JSON RPC was taking in the anything
in the order of about 250 to 300
milliseconds was done taking about six
milliseconds that's it so so you come
it's nice um yeah and the block pushes
out there in the public and you know me
just like 40 times faster yeah yeah yeah
yeah the the other example I can give is
you know all a lot of google cloud
services are exposing a gr pc interface
as well in addition to rest yeah some
like big table are only grp see so which
is if you care about them if you're such
you know if you're a if you're somebody
like big table and pub such like high
performance through borden in a QPS sort
of heavy systems then those are the
services which are seeing huge
advantages from from having a GF pc
interface so and and that the third one
i would say is which you know a lot of
google services themselves including our
core mobile apps are are actually in the
process of you know switching to gr pc
which which you know by the end of the
year or so i think we will we will have
some real numbers around what that is
mean but we are super excited with that
journey and the prospect of that nice so
i want to ask one question because i
keep on getting that question over and
over and if we don't ask it now it will
be the credit the equator they don't
show up we can you an air show up yet oh
yeah the show which is ok how do you
manage multiple versions of an API like
that's something that you have to do and
of course one of the options like well
never do breaking changes of course
bodies in the real world you will have
to do them how do you manage that with
jer pc right so this is the
an area where you know proto is actually
shined and done this well within Google
as well as you know people who use
protobuf outside would know that it sort
of gives you a backward compatibility so
for the you know if you if you've
written protocol files you've seen that
there's a unique sequence number
attached with GF every field and the
great thing with wrote above is that you
can add new fields to your message
formats without ever breaking backwards
compatibility so you know old binaries
or services that don't know what those
fields are or what they mean simply
ignore it right so thereby you can
basically serve multiple versions of
your services to different clients at
the same time without you know any
without a huge cost of change or without
breaking changes to existing clients
okay so with proto that's a great thing
right like people and this happens all
the time at Google people update the
protos you know push them in and the
great thing is you know all existing
clients continue to work you know those
who don't understand or don't know what
to do with the new fields just ignore
them right nice um so you can do stuff
where like if you added a field and then
somebody send in a message and like all
that's missing well then I'm gonna take
this coat down this path but it is there
then I will do the new thing right
whatever that happens to be and you can
kind of build in your cases as you need
to right right that makes sense that
makes a lot of sense okay cool cool so
uh you also mentioned that there was we
were actually trying to make grp see
something that is mobile first and for
mobile forces there's a couple of things
which is yeah performance newborn but
also data is expensive and slow so could
you could you talk a little bit about
that like what's the difference you see
our PC and all the things like maybe
like just a blob or maybe Jason or maybe
huge xml
like it's gonna be small thanks ml or JX
pecked or JSON XML which is a standard
oh yeah yeah so good you could do
discuss it every done with that yes so
from our initial you know from the
get-go we wanted to have gr PCB designed
in a way that puts mobile first so there
are there are a few answers right like
one which is straightforward is you know
basically both JSON and XML sort of do
you know base64 encoding as opposed so
instead of that with binary over the
wire that's like that is where you get
huge efficiencies and advantages from
what does it mean for mobile clients it
means less data usage means battery
savings which are you know critical in
today's times especially with and
especially if you're doing you know
things like real-time events yeah on
your mobile apps which are both client
to server as well as server to client
this is where again I think
bi-directional streaming from gr PC
helps a lot so in terms of you know
actual differences with with respect to
JSON or XML JSON XML effectiveness
ignorance is is something we obviously
depends in terms of you know actual
difference we get it depends on the use
case but if you go look at our you know
documentation around prod above just
binary you know serialization think is
it's three to ten times smaller than xml
serialization of structured data and
anywhere from twenty two hundred times
faster in terms of you know time to
process so remember a lot of these it's
not just about the payload size it's
also about the time to parse which which
you know in the remember your sort of
good old days of soaps and wisdoms and
XML parsing and
right so that is where a lot of the
development costs not just CPUs you know
cycles costs used to be spent so um I
think huge efficiency is to sort of gain
from there nice seems like it'd be a
really good fit for almost anywhere that
like when we we tend to think it's our
web applications as well but anywhere
that has needs low latency like I'm
thinking IOT we sort of touched on that
right obviously mobile as well gaming
could potentially be another option so
there's a lot of places that could that
could definitely fit yeah I think for
for mobile and you know having a bit so
we we you know we in our tent I think we
said it which is objective c for iOS and
Android Java both are something that
natively are supported for grp see and
you know we are seeing in fact the first
kinds of use cases we are seeing for
mobile apps are all around either by
direction of streaming or chat kind of
use cases and you know they or you know
wherever payload is heavily nested and
like sort of a complicated data
structure and nested deeply nested
payloads is where you'll see so the
biggest advantages of sort of binary
civilization but very nice very cool um
so I actually have a couple more
questions go on okay so one of the
questions is it's actually a
double-edged question which is okay so
why could I do this instead of just
sending binary blobs we're a binary
encoding right right so why don't I just
like whatever like in Java serialize and
just send that yeah so um it's like and
you know each of the languages have
their own you know such framework like
Java has a good autumn I library oh the
nightmares so uh you know it's it's um
there's a whole lot of answers to that
but you know primarily being the the
ability to it's not just utilizing on
the wire but like you know a standard
way to specify and share services
a a standard way to upgrade and back run
come backward compatible services and a
standard way we're not just how services
communicate but how services do
interesting things like health checking
monitoring tracing stats around them
this is this is where you know one
simplified approach for google has given
it a lot of benefits and has allowed it
to like really do great amount of
efficiency around reliability security
operations management analytics which
all become uniform and suddenly note you
know developers don't have to think oh
how will I talk to that system right you
don't have to think oh which languages
that written in you know i can tell you
my personal story out of my you know
right out of college driving you know
writing a see back end which was talked
to a java-based front end and trying to
hook jni libraries and always crashing
and you know it so and being very
specific to you know how two languages
communicate so i think the the if you
can take that body out and make sure it
works efficiently that's a huge huge
plus yeah and you don't have to worry
about oh is the java rmi library
supports this kind of civilization and
supports this structure but the one I'm
talking to actually does not so how do i
yeah i'm assuming they're also
versioning like what we're talking about
versioning on binary blobs just forget
it right they all need not even it right
yeah yeah so you've got like this whole
ecosystem around things and then you can
also sit back and be like okay I'm gonna
use the language that's the right tool
for this job yeah and I don't have to
worry about any communication at all
right and any new services you know that
keep coming up that I new mobile app I
write something new for IOT devices they
just don't have to worry about how I
will talk to my existing and new
services excellent get two questions oh
yeah so my question is I was floor
mother yeah so there was yet
it the other question is still again
about something really similar which is
a what if i'm using protocol buffers
I've heard about this other thing
flatbuffers what is the difference why
gonna use flatbuffers or can i use flood
buffers with your pc you can so actually
could you explain also a flop on vs so
there are various sort of variations of
protocol buffer out there for one is as
francis mentioned flatbuffers which is
basically you know trying to have at a
concept level you know basically having
data structure represented the same way
in memory and in disk so you kind of
don't have to take on this conversion
serialization and deserialization cost
and you know is something that is
picking up there is also another version
of protocol buffers called nano protocol
buffers which is for you no more for IOT
kind of scenarios making the the payload
even smaller and even lighter so one
great thing about grp see in terms of
its design and you know kudos to all the
all the engineers who you know started
with the design of it is it is designed
to be IDL agnostic right so in theory
you can swap in an ideal of your choice
instead of throat oh you can use
flatbuffers or nano PB or thrift or
other ideas for that matter and it is
you know you can use you can swap it out
there is some work on that but you could
in concept use it across ideas and while
i'm giving kudos on design the other
thing is it's not just ideal agnostic
but transport protocol agnostic so you
could in theory swap in HTTP to with
quick and in getting you know juice too
smart things like that which for those
of you don't know quick is an
implementation on top of UDP
and you know some high high media
payload use cases like YouTube are you
know really trying to take advantages of
those yeah we had a we had an episode
with alia gregorich and he discussed
HTTP two and create a little bit yeah I
was episode yes I don't remember yeah
for any listener that you listening to
this I just find that your leg great
very good soup too if you want to learn
more about quick and it's a joke yeah
definitely definitely awesome alright I
guess I'll I've one more question which
is what has been your favorite project
you've seen with grp see mmm that's a
good one it's a very good one clearly
yeah so I'm trying to see which which is
a favorite one so I'm not confident oh
I'm not confident yes so I'll name one
from from yesterday which the code i got
is one of you know in the top up there
which was a big client of gcp this is
trying you know pops up over a grp see
and this is something which is you know
pretty much ready like ready to be
released and they were sort of our early
testers and they have basically they
said okay we will try something like you
know a million messages per second and
this simple you know published to our
topic and subscribe sort of standard
pops up and you know they currently run
across huge number of servers and data
centers and they tested and they're
basically the developer was testing was
just like okay let me start on my laptop
and then I'll move on to data centers
and he pretty much managed to run out of
his small laptop oh and you know his
coat was I can serve half of my traffic
oh my job it seems I mean of course it
was a it was you know it was meant as a
joke and you know in terms of just he
was just trying to elude like surprised
by the amount of load he could just so
off a standard laptop
nice but you know I asked him can I
quote you on that you return the data
center I'm good but you know that just
speaks to um you know in certain use
cases you just see humongous performance
improvements and you know so so that's
that's one of my recent up there ones uh
other than that I think we are we are
very excited about what core OS is doing
with not just at CD but you know they're
using it across in their new thing
called rkt the new thing called tectonic
so it's a it's it's widely being adopted
within the technology stack and yeah we
are we're excited to see what at Google
and outside we can do with mobile use
cases in IOT as well well cool so I
think that we're pretty much out of time
we are we are so is there anything else
that you would like to mention before we
finish this interview we are first go to
grp see that I oh that's the first thing
you should do after okay yeah definitely
have that night Senate that does my call
to actions but yeah I mean we are doing
actually super excited to tell our
listeners that we are doing our first gr
pc meet up tomorrow actually it will
actually be yesterday and for ya oh
that's a VA let me let me be clear
specific on the date we are doing it on
31 6 p.m. PDT because you know we have a
global listener base so yeah from the
time you're recording you know 24 hours
from now so excited about that I think
we we we are actively looking to talk to
our community members and if you're
interested you know please join the
mailing list on grp c dash io at
googlegroups.com it's on GPC dot io
follow us on twitter at grp CIO and you
know would would love to talk more and
not just get your feedback but hopefully
even get contributions awesome excellent
well thank you so much for coming I
thank you so much for helping us
understand a little bit mirror it'll be
more what grp see is and what to use it
for yep thank you for your time preciate
thank you very much thank you so much to
varun for joining us today it was a
pleasure and delight to speak to you and
adds a big fan of GOP see really
exciting stuff yeah very very happy that
he finally came and also looking forward
to the event tomorrow gipc community
event down in mountain view it'll
actually be yesterday that yes yesterday
in it so and i'm very happy to see him
there yeah people from Korres people
from square Kelsey Hightower from our
team so I think it's gonna be a very
cool events give a really great event
cool so before we finish with this
episode we're going to go through the
question of the week and as we mentioned
at the beginning today it's going to be
about how to use firebase on mobile
applications yep and these like this
question actually comes from one of the
participants of launch hackathon this
last weekend in San Francisco and he
basically came to at our table because
he was considering using Google+
platform he's not very sure he came with
a bunch of questions and one of the
questions was okay how do I handle
authentication I want my users to use
password email and password and I was
like oh you should not do that like yeah
the best way to manage passwords is not
managing them so firebase probably
provides authentication with a bunch of
different methods like Twitter and
Facebook and stuff like that but also
provides a very nice way of doing email
and password so he used that and then
after that of course he put everything
on firebase because he was very happy
with it super easy so yay and his
question was like okay so now i have a
bunch of views and every single view
needs to access that data on firebase
what should i do should i create one
reference and pass it around or should i
create a bunch of references because
whatever like you can see this is why
gonna do it and my answer to him was
no idea so to answer that question we
decided to just walk around the building
and we found two awesome people that
decided to help us and just come
upstairs and talk to us so yeah we're
very happy to have sarah robinson back
hey Zara it's good to be back so sorry
who is a developer advocate for Google
cloud platform in our team and also
David East hey David thanks for having
me yeah thank you for coming the whole
four floors from third floor to the
seventh floor of the office actually
went up three flights of stairs she went
for both flights of stairs and then the
door was locked so I had to go down one
flight of stairs and then walk across
the building to the other and then walk
back across against oh wow we can get
you sandwiches yeah it's quite intensive
glad your exercise for the week so yeah
David David is a developer advocate for
the firebase team and I think that you
had a pretty good answer to this
question should i create references
should I pass them around what do I do
Oh like a lot of people in their first
new to firebase they think like all
right when I create this fire base class
you know initialize it it's kinda like a
database so it's really resources
resource intensive so I want to keep it
around and I want to make sure that I'm
not just like creating these big objects
that consume I was memory or you know
soccer balls data and that's not really
the case with the you know firebase
reference because when your app first
connects to you know your firebase
database that creates a persistent
WebSocket from your app to the firebase
servers and when you like create another
reference it doesn't just go off and
create another WebSocket the firebase
SDK just shares on that on the original
socket build so yours only ever one
socket connected to the server so you
don't have to worry about like Oh new
reference new socket new problems like
no it's all shares through the one so
you know the firebase SDK handles that
for you nice ah as far as creating them
you can you know create really as many
as you want you know like that's not
going to be the memory you know
intensive part the memory intensive part
is actually observing you know the like
you the real time listeners for the data
and that's really only as memory
intensive is how much data you're trying
to sink back because that's your
bandwidth is just bad
within slow internet connections are
slow internet connections so there's not
too much we can do about that but
otherwise you're totally fine with just
creating a new reference inside another
view controller or something like that
and and just synchronizing that data to
your views you shouldn't really be using
you know far base inside of you because
that like messes up you know the sacred
MVC of iOS but yeah but still like you
don't have to worry about like just
keeping one around yeah so it's not like
when you think about server applications
where you have like a database
connection with pooling its resources
and has all these connections it's much
more lightweight than that yeah exactly
so the answer for these these
participant could be when you sign in
you're gonna get a UID and you create a
reference rather than creating the
reference and then just passing it
around just puzzle you ad which is a
simple actually it gets even easier than
that you don't actually have to pass the
UID around because once you have an
authenticated user in the in firebase
you can actually for iOS you can say
whatever you could a new reference the
variable names ref so you say ref dot
off data and as long as that user you
have a currently authenticated user that
off data property will be populated with
the current user so you can say wrath
deta uid 0 and so I actually never have
to carry around any of the user
information because it's always
available on any reference you create ok
that's that's pretty awesome indeed yeah
there was actually a second part of the
question which was like ok so I want to
display a list of things he was a list
of skills actually and he was like also
I have to go through all the Jason than
getting the coding need and then adding
it to a different list will appear
somewhere and he was like this is kind
of like yeah you know I can do it but
it's kind of knowing that I have to
write it is there a better way of doing
this yeah there's actually a fairly new
library called firebase UI that helps
you bind your firebase data to a table
view in iOS or list view and Android so
it makes it really easy to just listen
for changes whenever that data is change
in firebase add the new item to the list
view cool so we'll add a link to those
two repos I must make it on github yeah
so on the show notes excellent well
thank you very much for coming and
helping us answer these questions today
yeah no problem thanks for having us ok
so before we finish this episode I
wanted to talk about the alternative
cool thing of the week we we talked
about Spotify which is a really cool
thing I'm very excited about it but
there's also a more personal maybe cool
thing of the week which is actually that
our podcast was uh launched publicly
yeah on on the Google cloud platform
blog yes and we've got actually a lot of
new listeners yes so if you're new to
the podcast welcome welcome and and it's
a it's amazing because we actually
created these podcasts thinking about
like you know I was like maybe someone
will be interested on listening to this
basket podcast who knows yep but we're
actually getting listeners from
everywhere in the world which is free
mg's awesome yeah I wanted to mention
something specific which is the second
biggest country for our listeners is to
pan that's pretty cool which is free
amazing yeah so yeah if you're Japanese
hey I'm very happy that you're actually
enjoying our focus I really like this
definitely and send us your questions
yes / stephane in English please don't
actually understand them to his Japanese
we do have some Japanese speakers who
could translate them in our team does
actually fits for people that experience
which is free quizzing only one of them
is Japanese yeah so yeah that's pretty
amazing cool so before we finish where
are we gonna find you mark next week so
I'm not gonna be anywhere special in the
next couple of weeks unfortunately um
but I did just get accepted for dev
objective sir web development conference
in Minneapolis cool which is aware we
14th of June nice so that'll be good
funnel be there talking probably about
something about communities I expect
something about coyotes who knows cool
I'm gonna be in San Francisco next week
for most of the week and then I'm gonna
be on my way to austin nuts for South by
Southwest very cool we're gonna have a
bunch of parties that's gonna be so much
fun though you're gonna have us yeah
everyone half cloud spin we're gonna
have
a bunch of talks and events and the
cloud vision API Robert and a bunch of
really cool things we have fiber space
there in Austin yep so yeah really great
space so if you gotta be anywhere in
austin next week for South by Southwest
come say hi we're going to be the fiber
space most of the time and we're gonna
have cool swag cool demos and probably
drinks at some point so come say hi
excellent so before we finish I wanted
to since we didn't do it last episode
and we have all these new list and we
have all these near listeners I think we
should do this which is how do people
contact us yeah if you want to send
these questions the wake up clings are
cool we definitely want to hear it yes
so people can send us emails at emails
okay you go over there hello at ecv
podcast com yep Twitter gcp podcast
reddit is the subreddit R / cheese be
podcast yeah google+ plus cheese be
podcast or you can also search Google
cloud platform park st definitely and on
the web on the web GC podcast com pretty
easy right so thank you so much for this
great episode had so much fun today me
too I'll see you next week see ya
you